all right daniel yes daniel where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
i'm originally from milwaukee wisconsin
uh a tiny village
uh called whitefish bay wow
and tell me about your family you had
mom and dad
yeah um i have a mother and a father my
mother
is currently retired she
uh used to
work
as um
in in
funding job training programs for people
and my father used to work as a
journalist for the milwaukee journal up
until he had a stroke in 1990
at which point he was
forced to retire because of
uh language difficulty and
therapy that he needed to take how would
you describe your childhood in general
i um i felt that it was it was
definitely sheltered
there were a lot of things that my
mother wouldn't let me do like watch
r-rated movies
um you know close my eyes during you
know sexual scenes and stuff like that
um
you know like blocking the playboy
channel
um but i think that
i was
i was i i want to say that my family did
treat me fairly i was definitely bullied
at school up through
through high school i want to say
by one or two people in particular
i was made fun of a lot not only for my
last name but for my
weight
and
it wasn't until
maybe
second year of high school when i
found
a group of friends that i really clicked
with and started getting all the toxic
people out of my life that i started
actually getting interested in what i
was what i was doing and studying
bullying is horrible for a kid isn't it
yeah um
you
you uh you have these arrangements with
people like they're gonna meet you after
school somewhere and you like you
get called a [ __ ] if you don't show up
and you
feel like this person is always around
next corner and then you have
altercations with them in the hallway
um i mean i was lucky that one
uh
staff member did spot us once took us
down to the vice principal's office and
the vice principal sided with me saying
that he was tired of this guy being in
there all the time
so he asked me if i wanted the police
involved but i said no so
um
that guy from what i read in the news
ended up being involved in a
drug-related
death of a
female friend of his and had to go to
court for
some reason but
yeah the
bullying
i wouldn't say it ever really stopped i
would say it toned down once i
kind of got away from the toxic people
you graduated high school yeah i
graduated
college i went to college you did yeah
and you're you're professional now
you're working
i'm working for myself as a videographer
and video editor
in new york city in new york city um i'm
in brooklyn
i
um
previously worked in atlanta
and then when that went kind of sideways
due to a lot of issues um
i went
back to milwaukee
and found there to be no work there
and then
up to new york where there was a lot of
work but it's also competitive yes so
yeah
and you've been married or you have
children i was married um way too
quickly to a girl uh
out of college
um
we were kind of rushed into it we had a
rabbi tell us you know if you're
in love why not just do it and so we
only dated for
god maybe about a year and a half and
then we had
our wedding down in atlanta and um
it was like i wasn't i wasn't really
feeling it i wasn't really in love with
her but
i felt that it was the next step kind of
thing
and that
that ended up ending due to my addiction
and my
inability to handle the finances as i as
i once uh did yeah so so you tend to
you're a gambler
yeah how long has that been going on for
you
uh
i want to say it was 2006 or seven
it's a whole while
and tell me how
how how extreme did your gambling get
it's
hard to quantify basically
i learned how to play uh texas hold'em
in atlanta
and uh it started as
um
bar poker
and that was the only legal thing
uh that you could do there was play for
bar cash but
because it was not legal there because
they
outlawed games of chance and only really
allowed scratch-offs
there were tons of underground games and
so
meeting people at these free
games eventually turned into underground
games
and
eventually turned
into full-out casino trips to other
states
and um one underground game i was at got
raided by a swat team
it was probably my fault i actually
wasn't there i was watching the world
series of poker
but
[Music]
when i would go and
get money to
um
go to this game i would hold it out in
front of me and the person who got
raided said that he that neighbors saw
people coming in with money so i didn't
have any clue how to carry it i was like
well i might as well just carry it
because i'm about to give it away
give it away in exchange for chips and
so that happened and
um
i would say it wasn't until i moved back
to milwaukee uh when
the
when i started using
um
methods of theft against my own family
when it
uh when really
really
hit
when it really got to a point of
un being uncontrollable
the theft had started
way earlier
um and this is something i have never
told anyone
um the
the
theft against my family they were under
the impression that i did it for the
gambling but the thing is that i had
already i was already very
astute at it
having
taken someone's credit card
information in college
and
reloaded myself through paypal
when i needed it
and buying myself things like clothes
and stuff like that
and after that it turned to
stealing from my wife's parents bank
account
and
after that it turned to my own father
and
at the time
it was uh
it was to fund uh gambling but the way
it started was just kind of to get by
and also just
kind of the thrill of like what can i
get away with
um
so
when it really got bad
my
my
my father was um
taking me me home from atlanta and
actually my mother was there too
but i happened to see how much she had
in his bank account because i went to
the atm with him just you know his
friendly thing
and you know he had about 25 000 in
there so i was like
you know i just saw as an opportunity i
knew where
you know he
he left his pants at night
he would
you know he would go to bed with with my
mother around 2 3 a.m and he would leave
his pants in the room
and i took the card and i also
started writing checks from his
checkbook to myself
and i ended up um
investing well i wouldn't say investing
but i ended up
putting the money about 400 at a time
into a
uh
online
site
um it was a sports betting site but they
had
uh poker and blackjack
and when i
uh when i started losing money at poker
i said you know screw this i'm gonna i'm
gonna just do blackjack because
i don't think a lot of people know that
a lot of poker players when they have
really really slow days they want to
like get their money back fast and
blackjack is kind of like a way to do it
and
somehow through
all the funding i managed to get my
account up to ten thousand dollars
and i remember sitting in bed and
not even
like completely just dumbfounded at like
how i did this
and but then thinking like all the
things that i could do if i
were to double that
and uh so i went on the next day and
promptly
lost it all
i remember i got down to sev about seven
thousand
i said okay i'm going to stop but maybe
i can get back to where i was
i was down at about five and then about
three and two and then
i just couldn't believe when it was zero
again i mean i had all these plans like
i was gonna
get the check
mailed and
you know possibly even repay my
dad so he wouldn't see that there was
money missing from his account because
he was the only one that i took money
from that i actually you know cared
about that stuff and
i gotten away with it before
and um
so
unfortunately he noticed it
and
because he had had the stroke he wasn't
really able to intervene or verbalize
this and he was slow to catch on i mean
i prayed on
you know i prayed on that vulnerability
and my mother stepped in and said how
could you
do that to him
and i wasn't at a point where i was
ready to listen to her and she said
um
well you have two choices you either
um
you know i'm either gonna call the
police
or you
decide you're going to go to gamblers
anonymous
every week at least
and i sat there and i was just like
i i made no
decision because i didn't want to give
up the gambling even at that point
and
after not giving an answer she said you
want to keep gambling and i said yeah
she says okay
about 10 minutes later i hear her knock
on my door and this woman says she's a
sergeant and uh
and so
i said i'm sleeping which i wasn't i was
lying in bed i wasn't sleeping
uh
she uh she entered and
through some
type of
verbal tactics she used she got me
pretty much to admit it right away
and she called in her partner who i
guess was a very young guy he looked
like he was younger than me at the time
and um i had never been rest before and
i was not about to
have this be my first time so
i literally called my mother up there
with my with my phone i called the house
phone which rang of course right there
and i said can you come up here this is
this is ridiculous i got
i got two cops on either side of me you
know trying to pull me
out of my chair
and uh it comes up and i said can you
just can you just cancel this because
like
i you know like this is getting
ridiculous and i i did notice that the
cops kind of deflated when i said that
and she said well i'm just going to do
whatever they advised to do and she
walked away
and the cops then
you know grabbed me again
my arms and i tightened them
i tried to grab the phone again to call
her again at which point they
smashed it out of my hand and
said um no you've lost the print that
privilege to do that
so i continued tightening my arms and
they just said you know
um
like you know just i don't remember i
can't really
replicate what they said without saying
my my name but
um
they eventually
uh called out a pepper spray
at which point i i was a little bit
educated and what that was so i
immediately closed my eyes and they
sprayed my eyelids
so i was like okay i open them up and
i'm like oh okay and that wasn't that
bad
and then one of them yelled taser
and
they tased me
in the front and i
just that was the
most horrible feeling uh ever it
basically just felt like i was being
electrocuted my entire body like it was
like
immobilizing
i
didn't know if i was gonna die or not at
that point
while i was being electrocuted or tased
the young guy shouted get on the ground
get on the ground
which point i got on the ground and i
basically just
just put my head down and close my eyes
and
he asked you know art
you know are you okay okay and i'm like
yeah you know the the poker was
addicting and i got really into poker i
bought books i watched tv shows i
watched
you know like i said the the the world
series i watched poker after dark i had
i knew all the names of all the greats
phil hellmuth phil ivey daniel negrano
the
phil laak um you know uh sammy
uh whatever his name is
antonio has found you know like all
those people just like is following a
sport and you know
and
like you know so i i knew all of this
and
it was like you know i it was really it
was blackjack to put me you know over
the edge but
um
i
i did not
see it as therapeutic but i went through
i went through the six months
i had my sponsor go into the casino with
me and banned me from the casino
um
and
then
uh i came up with this really
harebrained idea that if i go to work
for the casino
then
maybe that will help the gambling
addiction
i ran this past my therapist who thought
it was a terrible idea i ran a best my
parents who thought it was a terrible
idea i went through the training class
to become a blackjack dealer
i said i want to become a poker dealer
but they said that the chances of that
were very slim because once you get a
job as a poker dealer
there's very few openings
and uh so i went through i did i did
very well in terms of doing the math and
then
the the recruiter uh woman called me and
said um
yeah we can't hire you because you
banned yourself from the casino and i'm
like
oh well i'll just come in and unban
myself and she's like well if you unban
yourself you have to wait six months
and then so at that point i threw that
idea out
so then every single time i got my hands
on
a good amount of money
and this was very contradictory to how i
was raised and how i spent the first few
years of college where i was
very frugal and
was very good with money
every time i got my hands on some money
i was like yo i
think i can go and double it
and i went back to the casino that i was
banned from
several times a year
uh with maybe three hundred dollars or
six hundred dollars
and just having that much
you know um extra after all my bills
um i want to say every single time
it
i i lost every single time
uh from
yeah from like 2011 to 19.
and in 2019 when i finally moved here i
i made uh
within a few weeks i
found a place here
and uh
you know the first time
i hadn't done it in a while and i was
thinking
you know like uh like maybe you know i'm
coming to this with fresh eyes and they
don't know me and i'm this new person in
town and
i actually did walk out of there with
about like 1500 or something this wasn't
nearly going to make up for the fact
that i lost about 26 grand
during my whole
during from
2006 or 7 to 19.
about 26 grand including
money that my
my mother my parents gave me for
specifically for
you know trying to stop a foreclosure on
my condo and
specifically for
trying to get through a layoff
but
um
so it was something and then i ended up
going back
[Music]
several more times and lost every time
anything that i want was wiped out
during the time i was addicted i had all
the accounts i had the poker stars the
full tilt the
bow dog ultimate bat
i ended up on bad terms with every
single one of them because i
uh basically got to the point where i
had negative balances with all of them
there my bank account i even once i
wrote it
i wrote a check from the exact account
that i cashed it to so basically i wrote
a check from the bank that i was at
and then i
and then i threw it into the atm
and they actually credited me and then
later on somebody
said
somebody called me up and said we're
actually prosecuting these people and
i just hugged them
because that's what i was doing with all
the collection calls um
it's why my wife left by the house
eventually got foreclosed on she
she could not stand the fact that we had
we had a joint bank account and every
time money came in for her and money
came in for me
it went down below zero
and uh when i was laid off eventually
i would sit there in the casino until
midnight
wait for my unemployment to come in
and then hit the atm right at midnight
or maybe it was like 1205 1206
and that's how out of control it got and
um
i would be lying if i didn't say i still
fantasize about this
i still have
a lot of urges
um here it's a little bit harder i think
you know atlantic city is the closest
but the thing is that i still i can't
trust myself with any
large amount of money because if i
because before like expenses if i
put
if if i'm given a large amount of money
it's somehow going to get put into
gambling because i'm like what could i
do with this if it was doubled
is it the bullying that that lowered
your self-esteem and you're trying to
build yourself up somehow
being wealthy would do that it could
have yeah it could have been
the bullying could have been the desire
to be
a superstar looking up to other people
who had big personalities
who understood the game at a far deeper
level
than i did
um
but i was always an outsider i was
always very
quirky you know i always i had like a
stutter growing up i mean i've kind of
grown out of it i'm 40 years old now but
i still i still have it sometimes just
sometimes they can't think of the right
words uh to say and i in interrupt
myself
and um
but it's
it's hard to place it because it's also
carried over
to things like shopping
to things like overeating
to things that i get hooked on
like
if i you know if i
you know see have a piece of candy or
something that's like the best thing
ever i think like i need to have this
candy every day for the rest of my life
um
you know like i just i might just have
like an addictive personality disorder
but the thing is that
if you
you know there's something about like
it's never it's never enough for me it's
like if i were to double it
you know what i think about doubling it
again would i am i just the kind of like
let it ride person like if i were
to put my
money at a um i think it's what is it
like a roulette table or a craps table
where you can just sit there and never
take it back
i'm like that's what i would be doing if
that ever had worked out for me
like when i made the ten thousand
dollars online i was like
this could be 20 and i and i knew in the
back of my mind that if i had made the
20 i would be like this could actually
be 40. i think of all the things that i
could do
with the 40 but the thing is that it was
never really about things that i could
buy
with this it was just about thrill of it
it was just about the high of of winning
it was just about like feeling good
and i gravitate towards these these very
superficial things that make
me feel good i mean um
yeah like like gambling like food like
like shopping i i think right now i
probably have an amazon
addiction it's like it's like you buy
gifts for yourself
and i mean although i you know i i
eventually i got rid of all my poker
books and i stopped
kind of watching
the tv shows and you know i had i had
even a game running out of my condo at
one point after my wife left
and my parents made me give away that
table i mean it's
you know the desire it's like it's like
i want to feel the car it's like i'm
going to feel the cards in my hand
i'm like
you know i could go online i'm like it's
not good enough i have to see it in
person you know in 2018 i went to
seattle for a conference
in um
t-shirt selling and lo and behold
i
went to a casino in another part of
washington state
that that day i lost money
um
the next year i went to las vegas for a
conference yeah that was a great idea it
was a brand licensing conference went to
a casino obviously what else do you do
in las vegas right
everywhere i go it's like i would take
road trips and i would stop in indiana
at the horseshoe
and i would gamble there i when i was
meeting my wife to get some divorce
papers signed i took all the money that
i was going to give to the
uh to the person who was officiating
the ceremony
and put it on a blackjack table
and fortunately enough i actually came
out positive in the end but i had to
give 500 to the guy during the ceremony
i had to give 500 to my
ex-wife at that point and we were doing
at the time we were doing a jewish
ceremony it was it's called a get when
you get so just getting divorced through
a lawyer is not enough you need to get a
gotta get which annuls the katuba
and they had to bring someone in from
out of town which is why but i i
literally without even thinking about it
took all the money that i had to my name
and went to haras
in uh saint charles
and uh saint charles missouri and put
everything
on the blackjack table and i mean i
think it happened to be a high stakes
table and i
but you know when i look at the amount
of wins i've had and the amount of
losses i have
you know it's like it's like this losses
are probably up here but when you offset
them by the winds but still i mean it's
like i don't care it's like i want to
feel the cards i want to feel the the
camaraderie of having people around me
you know i wanna i wanna you know be
able to
talk and to rake in
big pots and
and to uh to be able to tip the dealer
you know big tips
even though they didn't really do
anything
you know but deal the cards i mean it's
just uh
it's hard to really describe what it is
because i hear
addicts talking all the time about this
like it's a rush it's a compulsion it's
a
feeling of
you know of um
[Music]
of uh
just just like just like i just like a
high just like uh
like you're you're stepping out of your
reality for a little bit
and it's hard
for me to say that i'm
just like a unique person that
like well i have my own personal reasons
and no it's really just that it's like
it's a surface level as uh
you know as um
you know to get
uncouth but service level is
masturbation is
you know um you know it just makes you
feel good for a short time and then you
just need more and more and more is it
some kind of replacement for love or
being loved do you think
it's possible and you boil it all down
to the very basic level of it all it's
it's
i
i think that
that is a good theory and part of the
reason i say that is because
i have an ongoing saga where i met a
girl who was really
just completely perfect for me in
college
and because of the way that i pursued it
i completely blew it
and when i
met my future
ex-wife for lack of a better word
everything i did was compared against
this one girl
and even my current girlfriend
everything she does is still compared
against this one girl
this is the girl that got away this is
the girl that i still have dreams about
and i don't think i've been in a
relationship where i felt real real real
true love
um because i'm always comparing it
against this one girl and funnily enough
she actually lives
in brooklyn um also uh about
i don't know
seven eight miles north of me
and maybe there's some part of me that
came here came here because of her i
mean i
you know basically checking in with her
i think she was
she's she's married now and owns a owns
a house or something but
uh you know works for um
like university
and uh
but
from
you know our interactions before i just
finally admitted everything to her after
the divorce i mean i had to wait till
after the divorce
um
i
i just i just could not believe that
this wasn't something that she felt also
and i just
you know i once asked her i was staying
at her place here
um on the way to an israel trip and
she took some time before saying no it
was kind of like
yes i mean did you ever feel that way
and she was kind of like
no
and i was like oh come on it's like
i'm like i don't know why
like i have to live this life
um
devoid of that type of love that i
feel that i deserve
and i feel like if i had been educated
more if i had had a father
wow this is like therapy for me if i had
a father who had actually
been able to communicate and hadn't you
know completely [ __ ] up his whole
life from
he was staying up he was
smoking you know he was drinking coffee
he was uh
had a job that was very stressful and if
he didn't have that stroke and you know
i guess he was born with a weak blood
vessel but if he didn't lose the ability
to communicate he could have taught me
how to
be with women
and uh
i would have had my first girlfriend in
in college
you know i would have i mean i was very
awkward in high school i was awkward all
through college up until the end
until the very friend that i was taking
money from you know gave me finally gave
me some pointers
and um
you know i mean i just feel like if i
had approached
that one girl
differently
um
you know things would be different but i
i i blew it i
just
came out with everything
you know
well i was still married and and the
minute she left i came out with
everything i had felt and it just uh it
was just the wrong thing to do
and it may be a replacement i mean you
might be right it might be an attempt to
recapture
you know the moments we did have
together from i want to say 2002 to
maybe six i mean yeah it was probably
like a four-year
friendship where i secretly you know
wanted her
and um to have dreams going on to be as
recent as
probably about a month ago
dreams that stay with me
that she appears in
um
is really uh is really palpable
and it's very real for me
uh that i went through that loss and
there has been
[Music]
there have been a lot of things that do
make me feel good but
um
as far as what i can envision life would
have been like had i
been with her
i don't know i mean my current
girlfriend is is cool but she's
i just don't feel the same
type of
connection that i did with this this one
girl
and uh it's one of those things where
you feel like you have that one you know
it's like in city slickers
that one thing
and i'm a bit pessimistic that i would
ever meet someone who
would
you know fulfill those needs in in the
same way that that she did
it's hard to describe what she did for
me but
um but
i don't know i just
it's it's it's a it's a
feels like an inextricable situation i
mean it really does it feels
like i
am hitting a wall kind of like
there is this
there's this
barrier preventing me from you know
finding real love and there's like
tons and tons of
addictive things and
i just like i'm like i really need to
learn budgeting again i really need to
learn money management again but it's
like someone sticks you know a couple
grand in my hand you know it's going
you know to the blackjacks going to the
po you know like someone
you know
like even if i'm trying to lose weight
someone orders a pizza
you know
like
i don't
but
i did not draw the comparisons between
my dad and
the
girl
and all of
but it did really bring it full circle
and um
it usually takes multiple
years i think of therapy to even make
that realization and i have had
several therapists and i never made that
realization i've told them bits and
pieces of it but
sitting here talking about it i realized
that it is all interconnected
and there are things that
i don't have any control over in my past
that are still informing my present
situation
all right daniel thank you so much for
being so courageous
thank you very much
you